so Tom tell me a little bit about the
award that you presented today we
presented the YouTube digital Innovation
Awards obviously seeing YouTube is a new
platform for getting working out there
there's a revolution in TV and film and
that because anyone can get their work
out there it can get seen the only thing
you can do is make your work original
and interesting and good and a market
quality I mean Netflix had just started
a relaunch at that house of cards I
tried completely different way to bring
our television and and and that just
means that all you can do you to put
your flag down and say you know I'm
worth watching is be good which is an
exciting time where suddenly you know
wonderful people once that people
doesn't have a monopoly anymore what
difference you think things like first
light make to young filmmakers coming
out what was great about this is that
the having this there are so many
obstacles as you as in the industry as
you know you go through it there are so
many things getting in the way and
things your face rejection in your face
projects not getting off the ground and
development process and that can knock
you so this ability to give young
filmmakers a boost this early on is
incredible it just it just it's it's
that encouragement it just gives you
some confidence that can go out and make
it in the real world talking about new
and upcoming projects what can we look
forward to from you coming out in April
is a show called da Vinci's demons about
the young Leonardo da Vinci written by
David Goyer sure who wrote The Dark
Knight movies and Man of Steel that's
coming out this year and it's
reimagining Leonardo Vinci in his 20s
and 30s as a young man in Florence not
not yet great but on the cusp of
greatness and how he he gets there it's
been the hardest thing I've ever done
one taking on the way if you play
Leonardo you take on the way of history
you take on expectations you take on I'm
only that we've taken on action and
stunts and explosions because it's David
Goyer and it's you notice it's a
superhero show pretty much and and it's
fun it's like just gloriously
entertainment so it's been a real laughs
to do what's it been like doing the
action as well the actions what I've
been bruised heavily bruised like from
tip to toe but but good like as long as
I've got a break
like a week in between the last one and
the next one I can heal and we were fine
so would you sign up for more could
there be more of them in the future I
think there's a strong chance that there
will be more very soon yeah first season
comes out in April and then if we were
to do more we might start very soon up
to that look forward to it can't wait
and what would you like to do after this
Oh after that I can't even think it will
be till the end of the year so I
wouldn't but I would love to do some
theatre I love theatre and I let's also
get back in there and we'll have been
two years because I've done the things
you know anything in particular appeals
I'd love to do so mad why I weren't in
New York last year two years ago and I'd
love to go back there
you